Жінки-засновниці стартапів
такі як СофІ Ченг - все ще рідкість
У Німеччині їх лише 14 відсотків - решта чоловіки
Софі займається платформою для медичного туризму.
Вона допомагає пацієнтам по цілому світу
знаходити закордонні клініки для лікування.
Такою послугою вже скористалися 40 тисяч пацієнтів
Своїм прикладом вона хоче надихнути інших жінок.
Я би хотіла, щоб у багатьох ситуаціях
жінки були відважнішими.
Можливо, мати менше самокритики та сумнів
і час від часу підштовхувати себе та
насмілюватися виходити за рамки, щоб щось започаткувати.
Найбільша складність для запуску стартапу
"вибити" гроші з інвесторів.
Чунг планувала зібрати мільйон сімсот тисяч євро.
І їй це вдалося
завдяки своїй упевненій манері та вмінню переконувати
Потрібно переконати і мотивувати команду.
Потрібно переконати потенційних інвесторів
які б надали кошти
Потрібно також вірити у свою компанію
Все це треба вміти
І все це, безперечно, є сильною стороною Софі
Добрі альфа-чоловіки зустрічають
добрих альфа-жінок і спільно працюють в команді
Раніше Софі працювала бізнес-консультантом.
Коли починаєш свою справу
доводиться долати великий опір
Ви відчуваєте величезну відповідальність
щодня ви повинні ухвалювати рішення
Для цього потрібні залізні нерви.
Її пробивний талант знадобився
зокрема, на цій зустрічі
у престижній берлінській травматологічній лікарні
Незабаром тут лікуватимуться клієнти її порталу
Це наша палата на кількох пацієнтів
для хворих з-за кордону
Під час переговорів Софі майже завжди
доводиться мати справу з чоловіками.
Сумно спостерігати таку нерівність
між чоловіками та жінками
Але, думаю, шлях, який я обрала
власне є внеском у те, щоб змінити такий стан справ
Хотілося б, щоб було більше жінок
зокрема і з боку лікарок
які б пробивали собі кар'єру до професури
або керівних посад у лікарні.
Перерва зі співробітниками у парку.
Це також складова її буднів
як і робота ночами та невизначені перспективи.
І те, й інше, каже Чунг, відлякує жінок.
Але приклад іншої жінки міг би здолати цей страх.
Рольові моделі - те, чого нам дуже бракує.
Я сама це бачу.
Майже немає успішних жінок-засновниць стартапів
якими особисто я могла б захоплюватися або взяти за приклад
І так само у багатьох інших сферах життя.
Якщо немає зразка,  якщо обмаль людей
які подають приклад іншим, як це можна реалізувати
то молодь навіть не може собі цього уявити
Майже половина співробітників старпапу Софі - жінки
Це випадковість, каже вона
Жінки у її компанії на рівні з чоловіками.